Our next speaker for the motion. Uh, Trevor Phillips to my rights, uh,
was chair of the equality and human rights commission between 2003 and
2012.
The co-founder of the diversity analytics consultancy Weber Phillips,
uh, and he is presently chairman of the index on censorship.
He's a director of the Barbican art center and vice president of the
Royal television society general.
[Inaudible].
Well, good evening. And thank you for inviting me to be part of this discussion.
I didn't really to be actually honest with you.
I didn't really know what intelligence squared was before I was asked to be part
of this. It's a tribute to their organization,
that this number of people can turn out on a lovely evening where you could
be doing something much better to listen to us. Thank you. So thank you so much.
So let me introduce myself.
I'm the 10th of 10 children of an immigrant family came here in 1950,
were descendants of slaves, including a woman,
the earliest known member of our family. She was called happy,
presumably some slave owners idea of a great joke. Further back,
we would have come from the Mandinka or Fulani people of West Africa like David.
He also comes from Guyana. That's a whole other identity story to tell you,
but were great. My ancestors were for Muslims,
but of course we had all that whipped out of us, probably in our case,
by the biggest plantation owners in British Guyana, John Gladston. Yes,
the father of the liberal prime minister,
William Glen's Gladston and the largest single beneficiary of compensation after
abolition. I also have a professional identity. I used to do TV.
Don't do much these days.
I've only made three films in the last 20 years before that with my
brother, Mike, I wrote the book and made the series,
which told the Windrush story. First, today,
I occasionally write for newspapers and magazines,
but mostly I'm basically a boring businessman.
I chair a talent business called green park. And for the past four years,
I was president of the council of the John Lewis partnership.
I run a small data analytics businesses,
probably a legacy of my time as a chemist. When I was young,
I set all that out to try to explain why I come at this debate from the
way I do my background may explain some of what
I say.
I agree with some of what Don said, by the way,
identity is more important because it now represents some real interests.
That for the first time in many centuries has a voice
women. Obviously minorities.
When my father came here,
the family who lived across the road could afford to be friendly with us.
They knew that no matter how clever my dad was,
how hard he worked,
how ambitious he might be when it came to getting a job or a house or a
loan,
we would never be ahead of them in the cute that to divide it up from
them, not income, not the area we live, but that thing,
that thing, and by the way,
it's not just poor people of color who suffer because we're having an argument.
No doubt about class here.
When I was chairman of the commission for racial equality,
the people who were most effected,
who wept in my office were not young black men Harris by the police.
They were the teacher who knew that because he was
black oration. He would never become a department head.
The lawyer who knew that no matter how clever
she was and how hard she worked, she was never going to take silk.
And the doctors who knew that they would always be junior
doctors and never consultants.
They had done everything that this society after them, everything,
but the prison of their skin kept them in the place
that meant they would never,
never reap the rewards of their diligence.
So I understand all of that. And if that's all that the identity politics about
what's it be short debate, we can all say we agree.
Some other things that it shouldn't, it it's not about.
I'm senior vice president who wrote and moved
and persuaded the annual conference in 1973 to adopt the no
platform policy. We wanted to keep fascist of campus.
Nobody today thinks that Jermaine Greer or Julie bindle should be in that
category. We can agree about that.
Nobody today thinks that white men should continue staging the sit-in
they do in the boardrooms of our great companies, except them.
We don't have to have an argument about that.
And nobody believes that it's okay to abuse public
figures. I got my first bag full of hate mail.
When I became the NUS president in 1978,
I was 24 years old and I had a whole bag full of it,
including a charming cartoon, which drew my own lynching.
Nobody will argue that that should be part of our politics.
So I don't think we need to devote a lot of time to all of that,
nor should we spend a lot of time comforting ourselves with the thought that
we're virtuous.
And there are folks out there who want the fact that none of us is Nigel
Farrage. Doesn't let us off the, on this issue,
clever and nice people can be racist to Albert Einstein
Caldwell, the Chinese and industrious filthy opportunities. People.
One of my friends and somebody I admire in politics
once called on the government.
He led to ensure British jobs for British workers.
We may tonight talk about institutional racism or sexism.
Stokely Carmichael came up with that phrase for a very specific reason.
It was a critique of Martin Luther King Carmichael said that point,
where he was making was that racism was so baked into society that you
could have a police force full of black angels,
and they might still be shooting black people.
Everybody said that don't be ridiculous.
50 years on the killings of young black men all over the USA,
often by black police officers says that Carmichael was
right. So tonight this is really for me about politics and its place in society.
There's only one reason for politics to exist.
And that is to help us solve problems. Now for over a century and a half,
our political architectures followed economic and social divisions workers to
the left bosses, to the right,
but we're in an era of extreme, possibly unprecedented disruption.
And the real tribal divide in our society symbolize the deepest differences
about what kind of people we want to be.
I'm a remainer pro globalization,
massively pro immigration pro technology,
socially liberal London centric you'd expect that,
but I don't disrespect my many relatives who live in say Essex or Nottingham who
feel just as passionately, anti-globalization cautious about immigration.
And that includes my black relatives, anti digitization,
and who load London's arrogance,
a survey taken after the referendum asked about people's attitudes to
various topics on the economy on capitalism.
There was absolutely no difference between remainers and leavers.
51% thought capitalism was a force for ill,
49% force for good asked about multiculturalism
71% of remainers thought it was a force for good
81% of leavers thought it was a force for ill.
60% of remainers were pro feminism lower than I expect.
74% of leaders were against feminism.
My point is it is these issues of identity that are dividing
us. This debate is really about one thing.
Identity politics is a politics that is tearing our society
apart. I think that's objectively true,
but perhaps where I differ with the other panelists possibly including
Lionel, is that they will all lament this fat. I don't,
I think it is a wonderful thing.
Appellants confront the world with timidity and the hope that the existing
political architecture can be tweaked and twisted into coping Polly Toynbee
versus Richard Little John labor versus Tori.
None of that worked for me or for 60% of the British people who say there is
nobody I can vote for. If you really believe in liberation,
this is going to be a struggle.
What makes you think that the straight white propertied men are going to give it
up without a fight?
Our society will be torn apart in order to get justice.
We need a political map.
Now that allows us to represent the true divisions in our society.
One of my daughters said to me,
when I told her what it was going to say tonight, Oh,
I see you're channeling Samuel L. Jackson. What the hell do you mean?
Well, she said Sam would just get up and he'd say this everything's
changing. Politics has got to change too.
Let's just tear this mother down and start something new.
[Inaudible].
Thank you very much, Trevor. Fortunately,
this isn't being broadcast live on the BBC,
cause there's quite a lot of bad language. I feel.